as we were discussing a decision on HS
to the high-speed rail link will be made
very soon someone who'll be keeping an
eye on that is Andy Burnham in there of
Greater Manchester he joins us thank you
very much for being on the program and
Boris Johnson and Robert Jarrett we've
been talking not about levelling up what
would you say it means about the
government's commitment to level up if
this hs2 decision doesn't go ahead well
that's very worrying isn't it so there's
a report in The Observer today that says
it's full steam ahead between London and
Birmingham oh but there's a review going
to happen
further north that's sounds like the
same old story to me Sophie London to
Birmingham gets a gold-plated railway
and we get a second class option or
maybe nothing at all so for a government
that's claiming to be standing for the
north I think this takes them into quite
quite quite dangerous territory so
you're worried then that Boris Johnson
may up may end up abandoning if you like
some of the northern aspects to the rail
system
we'll have to see the detail but there
may be an opportunity here though Sophie
just sort of give us a slightly more
positive look at it
we've never been convinced in Greater
Manchester about the design of hs2 on
our side of the country basically hs2
has been designed as a north-south well
railway and when you come to add the
east-west bit northern powerhouse rail
it doesn't work very well in fact the
east-west bit will be at full capacity
from day one if you ask people in the
north which one would they prioritize
most people would say get east-west
right so in many ways if government
ministers are listening this morning I
want to make a make an offer to them if
we can all agree that we now prioritize
east-west on the the western half of the
country get the design right at
Piccadilly get high-speed rail to
Liverpool more quickly then I think
that's something we could get behind
because we could look at the prospect of
a an east-west railway across the north
opening in the 30s 2030s hs2 is only
planned to come here in the 2040s so
there is
room for a compromise here and maybe
it's about taking the team who are
working on HS to north of Birmingham off
that project and putting them on
northern powerhouse rail redesign
Manchester Piccadilly to get it right
there because that's the crucial
bottleneck in the system and I think if
the government minded to go in that
direction maybe finally we can all agree
on that and the whole thing can move
forward but what I do have to stress
Sophie very clearly is the north of
England in my view needs new rail lines
that go east-west and north-south London
isn't being forced to choose it's
getting cross rail and it's getting HS
to so why always do we have to choose up
here if they build the east-west line
northern powerhouse rail early in time
they could then build HS to from the
north down to meet up with HS to in
Birmingham and that feels to me like the
right solution on our half of the
country and you know I put that out this
morning and in a spirit of compromise to
the government and and if they could
agree then I think we could all we could
all move forward on that basis and just
to finish on HS - you were talking about
the the need to prioritize the northern
powerhouse rail link potentially even
over HST and do you think that people
really get the people in government and
empowerment more generally really get
how bad things have been in the north
when it comes to the railways no I don't
and they're still really bad and
actually the governor still quibbling
about funding extra platforms at
Manchester Piccadilly Monsters the
bottleneck on the whole of the northern
system and so I know I don't think they
fully get that and it's still miserable
for people but to be fair they agreed
with what the mayor of Liverpool City
region Steve Rotherham and I said which
was to break up the north will bring the
northern franchise on the public control
and hopefully but it under devolved
control in time but on this question of
northern powerhouse rail sofa yes I am
saying prioritize that because if you
build this railway first as an east-west
railway number one you'll get the design
for that right but number two it will
open more quickly as an east-west
railway and that's what the public here
would say that's what they're they're
crying out for so that would be a line
from Liverpool Manchester
what monster Bradford Leeds and then
beyond and you know that I think is
something that we could we could all
support as long as in time we build that
high speed line south from Manchester to
link up with HS to in Birmingham okay
now while we've got you on keen to ask
about the Labour Party because after the
last election Jeremy Corbyn called for a
period of reflection but what we've seen
is candidates for both the leadership
and the deputy leadership effectively
saying that the message was right it was
the communication or the campaign that
was wrong at the last election do you
think the Labour Party is really coming
to terms with in getting to grips with
that catastrophic election result no I
don't I'm afraid it wasn't just the
message you know we've got a top-down
London centric Labour Party it's been
like that under Tony Blair Gordon Brown
Ed Miliband and also under Jeremy Corbyn
and and it was the message that lost my
former constituency which I'm talking to
you from now and it breaks my heart that
I have to say that this is no longer a
Labour constituency but changing that
position on brexit I'm afraid towards
what the I would say you know those in
the the kind of the London world were
saying to the leader that that ignored
labour voters here and they felt
disrespected and I've not really felt
that anybody yet has really really
understood that and nor can I can I say
has any of the candidates fully embraced
English devolution so myself and Steve
Rother and between us we represent five
million people we're labour in office in
that red wall with other mayor's like
Dan Jarvis and Jamie Driscoll but we
don't get invited to speak at Labor
annual conference we have no nomination
rights in this labor leadership election
we have no role in the recent general
election I'm even hearing that some
mayoral candidates for me are not
getting any support from the National
Party so I don't think they get it
labour needs to rebuild from here from
the bottom up properly listening to
people you know we're bringing through
policy Sophie that really resonate with
people here free bus travel for our
young people cut
the number of people sleeping rough on
our streets you know these are good
labor policies and it shows you don't
have to have a labor government to do
things that matter to labor people the
National Party we're almost invisible to
them so yep sorry sorry you say that I
just want to pick up on something you
said a bit earlier that answer you
because you say that none of the
candidates really get it if you even
worked out who you want to vote for then
if you quite disappointed with the race
so far well some of them have said some
some promising things so let me just be
fair but but I don't think they fully
spoken to what we're trying to build
here through devolution it's about
taking power out of Parliament out of
Westminster and really putting it in the
hands of people in cities and regions
like Greater Manchester Liverpool City
region you can tell I'm quite passionate
about this because I've been hard
queuing this Sophie pretty much for 20
years you know I ran to Labour
leadership bids myself two failed bids I
might say saying that labour needed to
kind of break out of the Westminster
bubble but I think it's still in there
and you know I'll keep saying this until
until Labour changes we've set questions
for the for the for the leadership
candidates because you know we need to
know in detail what do they think about
these labour mayors that we have what do
they think about English devolution if
we leave the whole question of
devolution the regions and the north to
the Conservative Party we will be making
a catastrophic historic mistake from
which we may never recover and just
finally do you think part of the issue
is that because of the way the
leadership contest is structured the
candidates are pitching to labour
members rather than labour voters which
are often of course people who have very
different sets of concerns so that's why
for example they're not perhaps
criticising Jeremy Corbyn that's why
perhaps they're talking more about
issues that are interesting to people
who are for example younger people in
towns in City in cities rather than
towns and in the South of England
I definitely think that's the problem so
it's probably why one of the reasons why
I lost to Jeremy Corbyn in 2015 because
I was thinking that we just lost another
election labour people would want to win
going forward
and perhaps my message was to pitched at
the country and not enough at the party
that's possibly why I lost it's a tricky
one Sophie to be honest but I do think
candidates need to speak to the voters
the voters are kind of half watching
them at the moment and getting a sense
of them and their message can't just be
for the internal audio okay lost
communications with Andy Burnham there
luckily you were right the end of that
interview anyway thank you so much I'm
Andy Burnham if you can hear me for
being on the program always good to talk
well apologies for some of these ads
technical issues there I think we've got
most of what and mr. Burnham was trying
to say that is it for this week but
don't forget you can listen to the best
bits for Show plus an extra analysis on
the sofa original Sunday podcast
available on the Sky News app on Spotify
and Apple podcasts after the break I'll
be going over every